hello guys and welcome to another
commentary video so sony pictures has
released a 55 second preview for the
home release of spider-man no way home
which featured looks at tom holland
andrew garfield turbo maguire and more
from the film set one of the most
historic moments in superhero movie
history is teased with an image of all
three spider-man standing side by side
tom holland poses in between andrew
garfield and toby maguire as they wear
their maskless spidey suits bringing an
image to life that seem nearly
impossible before spider-man no way home
the amazing spider-man star andrew
garfield sits down for behind the scenes
interview in the midtown tech science
lab as he shares inside information
about his return to the role making his
third appearance as peter parker and his
first in the mcu the spider-man actors
share a laugh with each other as they
recreate the classic spider-man point
and meme for the recently released still
image tivo mugai and andrew garfield
share a smile and embrace as they shoot
their final spider-man no way home
moments together toby's arm is over
garfield's shoulder as the actors soak
up the moment with golfers seemingly
taken in something hilarious from his
spidey predecessor tobin maguire stands
in his spider-man outfit without the
classic mask as he poses for still
images having been the first actor to
bring peter parker to a live-action
blockbuster movie maguire came full
circle by reprising his role in mcu 14
years later now there's also a quote by
tom holland where he says it was not
only an opportunity for andrew garfield
to make peace with the character in the
studio but it was also an opportunity
for me and him to have this moment where
we realized we could share this thing
now i think my favorite thing from all
this is that was actually a little bit
of an interview snipper release from
toby maguire which i'll play for you
guys now it's been killing me because of
the whole secrecy thing because i want
to go around and go like hey wait you
get on wires
i'm open for anything i'm ready to go
and that's about it to be honest with
you
so trippy mcguire here says he's open to
anything and he's ready to go which i
believe he is referring to he's you know
basically open to anything so if a
studio approaches him and then want to
make another movie with all three of
them or perhaps a spider-man 4 movie so
solo movie he'll be open to it and you
know he's ready to go ready to do it so
i really love this because all the
spider-man actors here are obviously
excited to play it a role and willing to
play the role again in future potential
movies so i think this just opens up so
many possibilities and i think the
chance of getting future spider-man
movies with andrew garfield and turbo
maguire or at least them having a
spider-man role in another film is much
more likely now anyway that's about it
for this video so what do you guys think
of this newly released footage
personally i really love that we finally
go to see them recreate the spider-man
meme that was a delight to see but let
me know what you guys liked and if you
haven't already please like and
subscribe and if you haven't already
please also turn notifications on so you
don't miss future videos